Now that we've seen
notifications in action,
let's step through the sample to quickly
refresh your memory as to how they work.
We'll need to understand how this works
before we can start adding wearable
extensions.
So let's open up Application
> Java > the Package, and
then open up MainActivity.java.
So let's now work through the code.
Notification ID here is the unique
identifier for the notification.
Each notification we generate
has a unique value and
if we issue two notifications with
the same ID, we override the first one.
The interesting code is in
sendNotification, which is here.
This creates an intent that is fired
when the notification is clicked
by the user.
We need to create a new
pendingIntent here, so
that the notification service can
run the intent later on for our app.
We need to setup a builder for
NotificationCompat objects.
We'll call methods on this to set it up.
This sets up the icon to show for
the notification.
This tells the notification what pending
intent to use, which we created earlier.
And this here makes the notification
automatically disappear when it's
clicked on.
This here is a different kind
of icon used on the left side of
the notification in
the notification shade.
These three lines configure
the main title, the main text, and
also some subtext, all of which are
shown in the notification on the phone.
This grabs a reference to
the notification manager.
And this takes the builder and
generates a notification compound
object using the .build method.
And passes it to the notificationManager
using the NOTIFICATION_ID value.
The NOTIFICATION_ID value must be unique
amongst the other notifications you
might want to create.